I'm getting a caffeine high already
we've had two cups
ever since I got the Hollywood I've been
a complete coffee snob like I care too
much about my coffee and like I need my
coffee I'm very particular about what I
like and what I don't like I drink a lot
of coffee but I don't know how to make
it I used to be a briefs way back in the
day so coffee is kind of my thing
I'd say this is maybe like a medium brew
versus a lighter prove let's taste a
little oaky to me it does taste the way
it looks which is like darker and more
like I'd say more robust it's a moist
soak in it but still weak
I'm not mad though it's a long the basic
category I would say but it's it's not
the most basic oh this is Starbucks I
would say it costs maybe two bucks and I
would pay two bucks this is definitely a
dollar 85 and I'd say two possible it's
like a dollar fifty aha wow I really am
I mean she does have saw bucks right
there
Coffee smells flat it's kind of buttery
smell I feel like the nicer coffees have
a higher sweeter taste at the top and
this is like it goes down really smooth
and has like a little hint of something
at the top I take it definitely tastes
sour
I would pay 50 cents for this I wouldn't
pay for this I'm scared to be wrong here
cuz I I really like this coffee and I
think I would pay $4 for seven oh my god
seven dollars is worth $7 it's actually
really good what are these notes I don't
even know in know what this is and it
feels tropical it's got it's got a UH
and I see trees when I smell it it's
like your pretentious smell like why is
going like this I feel like I'm gonna
regret this if I'm wrong but it tastes
sophisticated
they must have infused something in this
I don't know what this is I think it
cost three dollars yeah five dollars for
this coffee this is I think what this is
this is too complex in my snobbery
there's barely any bitterness to this I
mean it's I don't want it just smells
pretty standard this is like free office
coffee and I wouldn't pay for it
free office coffee and I wouldn't pay
for it there's nap over charging I'd say
one dollar evening yeah get rid of that
79 cents
Starbucks to me was my favorite one
because it kind of included all those
things that I look for in a cup of
coffee the coffee commissary one out of
all of them like I it got me thinking
like it was like whoa like something
happened here and like it it wasn't just
like the run of the mill a run of the
swill if you will
coffee okay doctors